- [Voiceover] Write
the first nonzero terms
of the Maclaurin series for e to the x.
Use the Maclaurin series for e to the x
to write the third-degree
Taylor polynomial
for g to the x is equal to e to the x
times f of x about x equals zero.
So Maclaurin series, if
that looks familiar to you,
watch the videos on Khan
Academy on Maclaurin series.
I'll give a little bit of primary here.
For taking the Maclaurin series of f of x,
that's going to be equal to f of zero.
We could view this f of
zero times x to the zero
over zero factorial,
if you assume zero
factorial is equal to one,
and then plus f prime of zero
times x to the first over one factorial
plus f prime prime, the second
derivative evaluated at zero,
times x squared over two factorial.
I think you see the pattern here.
Plus f prime prime prime,
the third derivative
evaluated at zero of x to the third power
over three factorial.
I think you see where this is going.
And of course, this
first one, x to the zero
over zero factorial, that's just one.
So oftentimes it will
just be written f of zero.
And this term one factorial is just one.
So oftentimes it's just
a zero, and this f prime
of zero times x, so on and so forth.
So, actually, let me just write
approximately right over there.
And so let's do it for e to the x.
So e to the x is approximately equal to,
well it's going to be e
to the zero which is one.
Plus, you might already know
that f of x.
If f of x is equal to e to the x,
then f prime of x is
also equal to e to the x.
That's one of the magical
things about e to the x.
The slope of the tangent
line at any point is,
well, equal to the value is
equal to the x value there.
And if you take the third
derivative or second derivative,
it's also, you're gonna get as
many derivatives as you want.
You'll still get e to the x.
That's one of the special things about e.
So the first derivative evaluated zero,
well that's still e to the zero
power times x to the first.
So plus x.
And then we have the second
derivative evaluated at zero.
Well, that's still one.
So it's going to be times,
or so it's one times
x squared over two factorial.
So we just say plus x squared over two,
plus x squared over two.
Two factorials is two times one
and then plus.
Once again, the third
derivative evaluated at zero,
that's just e to the x evaluated at zero
which is e to the zero which is one.
So x to the third over three factorial.
So plus x to the third
over three factorial.
We could write it as three factorial
or that's three times two times one.
That's equal to six.
And then we keep going.
So we just wrote the
first four nonzero terms
of the Maclaurin series for e to the x.
That's one, two, three,
four nonzero terms.
Now we wanna use, so let
me just underline that.
That's part of what
they're asking us to do.
Then they say use the
Maclaurin series for e to the x
to write the third-degree
Taylor polynomial
for g of x which is equal to the product
of e to the x and f of x.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna write
our original f of x.
Let's write down the
first few terms of it.
And then what we could
do this thing about,
well, how can we multiply
those two polynomials?
And we just have to know
enough about the multiplication
of those two polynomials
to just get us our
terms that are no higher
than third degree.
So f of x is approximately equal to,
let's see, it's x, I have a bad memory,
it is x minus 3/2 x squared.
X minus 3/2
x squared and then,
plus three x to the third power,
plus three x to the third power.
Plus three x to the third power.
Plus, and actually you
could say minus if you like
because that is gonna be,
you are gonna have, it's
plus minus plus minus,
however you want us to do it.
And that's enough.
And, why do I feel confident
that that's enough?
Well, we only want we only want to write
the third degree Taylor polynomial.
So if we multiply this
and we involve terms
that are higher than third degree,
well, we're gonna, that's going to give us
the terms that are polynomial
that are higher than third degree.
So let's just think about it.
What's gonna be the product?
So e to the x times f of x.
That's going to be approximately equal to,
well let's see.
We are going to multiply
this infinite polynomial
times this infinite polynomial
and that might seem
intimidating to you at first.
What you could do is you could
go for each of these terms.
Must start multiplying it
times each of these terms at here.
Essentially, you know, when
you're multiplying polynomials,
you're just repeatedly doing
the distributive property
so you take this and
distribute it on that.
But we should only worry about the terms
up to third degree because
anything beyond that,
well, that's going to add up
to a higher than third degree term.
So x times one is x.
X times x squared,
or sorry, x times x is x squared
so plus x squared.
X times x squared over two is
x to the third over two.
So I'll just write plus 1/2
x to the third power.
And I'm gonna stop there
because if I do x times that,
that's gonna be fourth degree term
and I don't wanna worry about that.
We are writing the
third-degree Taylor polynomial.
So that's x, x squared,
x to the third over two.
So now let's distribute
the negative 3/2 x squared.
I'll use another color here
just to help explain it a little bit.
So if you multiply that times one,
that's going to be minus 3/2 x squared.
I'm just going to a second line here
so I can line things
up and add them nicely.
And then this times this is
negative 3/2 x to the third.
Negative 3/2 x to the third.
And once again, I'm gonna start there.
If I multiply these two, I'm
gonna get a fourth degree term.
I don't care about the
fourth degree terms.
And then, and then,
let's do, let's worry about this guy.
And so let's start distributing.
So if I multiply it times this one,
I'm gonna get three x to the third power.
Three x to the third power.
And I'm gonna stop there.
Because then if I start
multiplying it times that guy,
it's getting me a fourth degree term
and then a fifth degree term
and then a sixth degree term
which I don't need to worry about.
So these are all the pieces
that are going to make up
that third degree polynomial.
And so, what is that going to be equal to?
What is that going to be equal to?
This is a little bit of,
you know, getting your math
intuition for multiplying
infinite polynomials.
Let's see, you're gonna have x.
And then you're going to have,
this is one x squared
minus 1 1/2 x squared.
So that's going to be
negative 1/2 x squared.
Now let's see.
Here, you have plus 1/2 minus 1 1/2
which would give you negative two
and then plus three,
plus, no, sorry,
1/2 minus 1 1/2
which would be negative one
plus three is positive two
plus two x to the third power.
So we could say e to the x times f of x,
the third degree Taylor
polynomial for this is
x minus 1/2 x squared
plus two x to the third power.
And we are done.
So this was a little bit tricky.
You have to appreciate how
to, and besides calculus,
it's a little bit of just algebra.
I just appreciate, okay, I
only need the third degree.
I don't have to distribute this
times the infinite number of terms.
Because, at first you might
say, "That's super hard.
"How do I multiply two
infinite polynomials?"
The key is we only worry
about the third degree,
up to the third degree.